very tough day today for supporters of
Elizabeth Warren yes yes that was uh
that was big news today Elizabeth Warren
announced she's ending her presidential
bid yeah apparently America isn't ready
to have a president who's only 70 just
not
I think we like our presidents now to be
about eight nothing else when you're
when you're that young you make rash
decision President Trump continues to
delight last night last night President
Trump appeared on Fox News and said he
has quote a hunch the coronavirus isn't
as bad as health experts say and ladies
and gentlemen I have a hunch we're all
gonna die yeah I really
they really did pay you with a parking
lot I just told the whole crap yeah
everyone's doing their part with the
coronavirus a Starbucks just announced
they are cleaning their cafes every
eight minutes because of the coronavirus
yes also they've stopped serving their
popular vanilla sneeze latte I got to
the end of that one and realized how
stupid it boy and I couldn't do it I'm
sorry
but anyway I did it and no one got hurt
here's your stain tank on this whole
story because of the coronavirus Tito's
vodka you know them Tito's vodka is
asking its customers this is true to not
use their vodka to sanitize your hands
yeah yeah Tito said our vodka is more
for washing your balls that's
repor there goes my free case' tito's I
thought I thought that was an
endorsement yeah I think ya want clean
balls
Tito's yeah I'm sure they'll use that
yeah